Odpowiedzialne przetwarzanie rozumiane jest
jako rozwijanie quantum computing
ze świadomością jego mocy
i potencjalnych skutków — kiedy mówimy „odpowiedzialne"
mamy na myśli rozwijanie i używanie technologii
w oparciu o z góry określone zasady, które pomagają nam zapobiegać
potencjalnym szkodom i je ograniczać,
przy jednoczesnym promowaniu rozwiązań, które są proaktywnie
inkluzywne i rozliczalne. W IBM
kierujemy się poczuciem odpowiedzialności
wobec społeczeństwa od dziesięcioleci. Dziś nazywamy siebie katalizatorem,
który sprawia, że świat działa lepiej. Oznacza to, że
mamy obowiązek rozważyć konsekwencje
technologii, które budujemy i pomagamy wdrażać.
Rozwijając tę nową technologię,
decyzje, które podejmujemy dziś, będą kształtować przyszłość,
a te decyzje
mogą mieć ogromny wpływ na społeczeństwo.
Na przykład możesz stanąć przed wyborem: realizować aplikację
pomagającą tylko kilku interesariuszom, czy też
taką, która może rozwiązać problem społeczny.
Mamy nadzieję, że jako klient będziesz w stanie myśleć
o odpowiedzialnym rozwoju quantum computing —
odpowiedzialne myślenie może pomóc Twojej firmie zbudować zaufanie
inwestorów i konsumentów,
a także budować reputację opartą na integralności
i szacunku wśród pracowników
i klientów. Z drugiej strony
może pomóc Ci uchronić się przed złą prasą, grzywnami
i karami. W tym filmie
przedstawimy ważne kwestie dotyczące odpowiedzialności,
które warto omówić ze swoim zespołem,
kiedy badasz quantum computing
i jego zastosowania. Jeśli chodzi o quantum computing,
odpowiedzialne myślenie i działanie
oznacza przestrzeganie zbioru zasad
i wartości, które kierują Twoim rozwojem
i wdrażaniem technologii.
Na przykład oznacza to bycie transparentnym
zarówno co do ograniczeń, jak i możliwości
quantum computing. Mamy dziś w naszym języku
i kontraktach zapisy, które wymagają od klientów IBM Quantum
odpowiedzialnego korzystania z naszych systemów
i zabraniają im używania naszych systemów
do celów niegodziwych lub nielegalnych.
Nazywamy to klauzulami odpowiedzialnego
i dopuszczalnego użytkowania.
Ten język już teraz wpływa na to, jak nasi klienci myślą
o rozwijaniu quantum
dla swoich przypadków użycia. Możemy też
pomagać kształtować kierunek quantum computing,
decydując, które aplikacje rozwijamy
i akcelerujemy.
Aby chronić przed potencjalnie nieodpowiedzialnym używaniem
naszej technologii, opracowaliśmy też solidne rozwiązania IBM Quantum
bezpieczne. Kiedy myślisz o tym, jak
i do czego używać quantum computing,
zadbaj o to, by realistycznie mówić o swoich oczekiwaniach
względem quantum computing i harmonogramach,
w których planujesz je wykorzystać.
Nie przedstawiaj quantum computing
jako czegoś tajemniczego — staraj się wyjaśniać je realistycznie
jako sprzęt komputerowy,
który podlega zasadom fizyki kwantowej.
Zadbaj o to, by Twój przypadek użycia quantum computing
był proaktywnie inkluzywny
i uwzględniał wszystkich potencjalnych interesariuszy,
żeby ocenić skalę
ewentualnych negatywnych skutków społecznych.
Upewnij się, że masz jasno określone zasady
i wartości dla eksploracji swojego przypadku użycia
i jego rozwoju. Dziękujemy
za obejrzenie i mamy nadzieję, że
wnosząc użyteczne quantum computing na świat,
będziesz też myśleć o tym, jak robić to odpowiedzialnie.
The the